A quick warning, there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
先作个简短的警告，本期节目中包含未经消音的脏话。如果您更喜欢消音版本，请前往我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 收听。
There was this article that a comedy website put out last year. Did you see this one? This was when cities first started going into lockdown. The headline said, "Nation's dogs effing loving whatever is going on right now." Apparently, that wasn't every dog. Lauren's dog, Raffi, 50-pound boxer mix, was a kind of vigilant, super protective dog even before the pandemic. And then, once lockdown started--
去年一家喜剧网站发布了一篇文章，你们看过吗？那是城市刚开始实施封锁的时候。标题写着：“全国的狗狗非常喜欢现在发生的一切。”显然，并不是所有的狗都这么想。劳伦的狗拉菲，是一只 50 磅重的拳师犬混种，在疫情爆发前就非常警觉，保护欲极强。然后，封锁一旦开始——
The problem was everyone was ordering stuff online, and there were a million delivery people coming. There was FedEx, UPS, USPS, Amazon all day long. Or my neighbors would be coming and going. And the minute-- I couldn't even hear a delivery truck coming up the street, and already, the dog jumped on a chair that was near my window, was peering out, just fully at attention, ears pricked up. That's when I started to see his anxiety amped up, right? He couldn't get any rest. He couldn't calm down.
问题在于每个人都在网上购物，有数以百万计的快递员送货上门。整天都有联邦快递、UPS、美国邮政和亚马逊的快递。或者我的邻居进进出出。只要一听到——我甚至听不到快递车开进街区的声音，狗狗就已经跳上了我家窗边的椅子，向外张望，全神贯注，竖起耳朵。那就是我开始发现它焦虑加剧的时候，对吧？它无法休息。它无法冷静下来。
In the house, he was always barking and growling and couldn't settle down. The fact that Lauren was now home all day with him-- which, for lots of dogs, would have been the greatest thing that ever happened to them-- for Raffi, just made things a lot worse.
在家里，它总是吠叫、低吼，无法安定下来。事实上，劳伦现在整天都和它待在家里——这对很多狗来说，可能是它们经历过的最好的事情——但对拉菲来说，情况反而变得更糟了。
Dogs like him, they need a break, right? They need a break from the vigilance to say, I don't need to guard this person anymore. This person's out of the house. I'm chill. They need to not be on the job all the time. And I think that he was on the job all the time. And that was the problem.
像它这样的狗，它们需要休息，对吧？它们需要从这种警惕状态中休息一下，告诉自己：“我不需要再保护这个人了。这个人出去了。我可以放松了。”它们需要不必时刻处于“工作”状态。我认为它当时一直处于“工作”状态。这就是问题所在。
She took him to a behavioral veterinarian, who told her that lots of dogs were going through this since the pandemic. They put Raffi on meds-- meat-flavored Prozac. It didn't fix the problem. He got worse and worse. On walks, he was suspicious of people, which he had never been before. He ran across the room and burst through the door to chase and bite a FedEx delivery man. He lunged at someone on the stairs of the building. Lauren set up an appointment with a trainer who specialized in aggressive dogs.
她带它去看了一位动物行为兽医，医生告诉她，自从疫情以来，很多狗都出现了这种情况。他们给拉菲开了药——肉味的百忧解。但这并没有解决问题。它变得越来越糟。在散步时，它对人产生怀疑，而以前从不会这样。它冲过房间，撞开门去追咬一名联邦快递员。它扑向楼梯上的人。劳伦预约了一位专门训练攻击性犬只的驯犬师。
And finally, Raffi attacked a little girl, maybe eight or nine years old. Just burst through a latched gate at a community garden where dogs run off leash. Lauren was guarding the door to make sure nobody entered while Raffi was in there, but he rushed past her to get to the girl, breaking through the gate.
最后，拉菲袭击了一个小女孩，大概八九岁。当时在社区花园里，那里允许狗狗不牵绳奔跑。拉菲冲破了一个带插销的栅栏。劳伦当时守在门口，以确保拉菲待在里面时没人进来，但它冲过她身边去追那个女孩，撞破了栅栏。
And the girl fell down, and the dog just got on top of her.
女孩摔倒了，狗直接扑到了她身上。
Oh my God.
天哪。
So terrifying. I mean, the dog probably weighed almost as much as the girl did. And I mean, I was just devastated for the girl.
太可怕了。我的意思是，那只狗的体重大概和那个女孩差不多。我真的为那个女孩感到心碎。
The girl was upset and crying and walked away limping. Lauren's an experienced dog person. She worked with three different trainers when she first got Raffi to deal with his aggressiveness towards other dogs. But the fact that these attacks since the pandemic were completely unprovoked and on people, the fact that the meds weren't working, that Raffi seemed perpetually agitated and just changed, she thought about putting him down. She felt like she had no choice.
女孩很伤心，哭着走开了，一瘸一拐的。劳伦是一个有经验的养狗人。她在刚养拉菲时，曾请过三位不同的驯犬师来处理它对他人的攻击性。但疫情以来的这些攻击完全是无端发生的，而且针对的是人，加上药物也不起作用，拉菲似乎一直处于一种持续的焦躁状态，性情大变，她考虑过将它安乐死。她觉得自己别无选择。
And I wrestled with those things. I mean, it's an excruciating decision to make. I've had dogs before that I've had to euthanize because they are old or they're sick. And you're putting them out of their misery. And this was a totally different experience because you're taking a perfectly healthy being that loves you more than anything, that would do anything for you--
我一直在纠结这些事情。我的意思是，这是一个非常痛苦的决定。我以前养的狗因为年老或生病，我不得不将它们安乐死。那是为了解除它们的痛苦。而这次经历完全不同，因为你是在终结一个完全健康、比任何东西都爱你、愿意为你做任何事的生命——
Well, yeah. And, in fact, is trying to protect you.
是的。而且，事实上，它是在试图保护你。
Right, right, and trusts you. But a completely unprovoked attack like that? There's nothing you can say about it. There's no way you can reason yourself out of what has to happen next. If you go after a kid, you're done, you know?
没错，没错，而且它信任你。但是像那样完全无端的攻击呢？你对此无话可说。你无法说服自己接受接下来必须发生的事情。如果你去攻击一个孩子，你就完了，你知道吗？
She decided to put Raffi down.
她决定将拉菲安乐死。
It's truly the most heartbreaking decision I've ever had to make in my life.
这真的是我一生中做过的最令人心碎的决定。
It's the anniversary of the first COVID case in the United States. When you first heard of COVID, could you have imagined that it would have touched you in this particular way, that you'd end up not having your dog?
现在是美国首例新冠病例发生的一周年纪念日。当您第一次听到新冠疫情时，您能想象它会以这种特殊的方式影响到您，让您最终不得不失去您的狗吗？
There is no world in which I would think that this would be the logical outcome of COVID, that I would have to put my dog down, that COVID would ever have any impact on my dog. I mean, of all of the possible probable outcomes of a global pandemic, my dog dying is not one that I could have ever imagined.
无论如何，我都不会想到这是新冠疫情的必然结果，我竟然必须将我的狗安乐死，新冠疫情竟然会对我的狗产生任何影响。我的意思是，在这一全球大流行的所有可能后果中，我的狗死亡是我永远无法想象的。
There are certain consequences of the pandemic that we all know-- over 400,000 Americans dead, millions of people out of work, kids everywhere having these terrible school years with distant learning. But there are all these other ways the virus has altered and shaped our lives. I was talking to this woman, Cindy, in Lincoln, Nebraska about this thing that happened a few days after her dad died of COVID. She was bringing her minivan into the garage and realized, oh, right. My dad isn't going to teach my son to drive.
我们都知道疫情带来的一些后果——超过 40 万美国人死亡，数百万人失业，到处都是孩子们在艰难地进行远程学习。但这种病毒还有许多其他方式改变和塑造了我们的生活。我正在和内布拉斯加州林肯市的一位女士辛迪谈论她父亲死于新冠几天后发生的事情。她把小型货车开进车库时意识到，噢，对了。我爸爸不会教我儿子开车了。
I think it was-- I was just parking. I think I was parking my own car and putting my hands on the keys and just thinking, oh, wait. That's another thing that we're going to miss now.
我想当时是——我只是在停车。我想我正在停自己的车，把手放在钥匙上，然后想到，哦，等等。这是我们现在会错过的另一件事。
Her son Harrison and her dad were really close. And she felt good knowing that her dad was going to teach him to drive. She says Harrison's really smart and funny, but not everybody gets him.
她的儿子哈里森和她父亲关系非常亲密。她曾感到欣慰，因为知道她父亲会教他开车。她说哈里森非常聪明、风趣，但并不是每个人都能理解他。
And he and my dad really got each other. And they could just hang out, make funny jokes, ask questions, quiz each other. As a matter of fact, I was just looking. I have a-- there's a toy plastic soldier sitting on my desk.
他和我很懂对方。他们可以待在一起，讲些有趣的笑话，互相提问，互相测验。事实上，我刚才还在看。我桌上放着一个塑料士兵玩具。
When her dad had open heart surgery, Harrison brought a few of these little plastic green soldiers to his hospital room.
在她父亲进行心脏直视手术时，哈里森带了一些这样的小塑料绿人士兵去他的病房。
And said, these will protect you while you're in the hospital, Grandpa. And so, my dad started staging battle scenes from his hospital bed. And there was candy and Kleenex. And then he would text them-- photos-- to my son and say, hey, Harrison, look. Here's-- you know. Anyway, those were the kind of things that they would just do with each other.
他说：“爷爷，这些会保护你在医院的安全。”于是，我父亲开始在病床上摆弄战场场景。还有糖果和纸巾。然后他会把照片发短信给我儿子，说：“嘿，哈里森，看。这是……”总之，那些就是他们会一起做的那些事。
Anyway, driving-- not a huge thing, just a small, specific loss. Harrison's 16th birthday, the birthday that you can get a driver's license, was just a few weeks after her dad died.
总之，开车这件事——不是什么大事，只是一个具体的、小小的损失。哈里森的 16 岁生日，那个可以考驾照的生日，就在她父亲去世几周后。
So who's going to teach him now?
那现在谁来教他呢？
I don't know if we'll have to-- I suppose we'll take turns, my husband and I. Yeah, we haven't talked about it anymore, though. I think we all kind of know it's hanging there. And in some ways, not moving on with it maybe is a way of still kind of that magical thinking of, oh, maybe we don't have to think about it another way, even though we all know that's the reality.
我不知道我们是否必须——我想我们我和我丈夫会轮流来。是的，我们没有再讨论过了，虽然。我想我们都知道这件事悬在那里。在某种程度上，不去面对它，可能是一种依然保留着某种“魔法思维”的方式，即：噢，也许我们不需要换种方式考虑它，尽管我们都知道这就是现实。
Cindy said this one thing to me that really caught me by surprise. We were talking about how, since her dad died, she's connected to this whole community of people online who've lost family members to COVID. And I asked her what people have said that's been helpful, expecting her to say, it's been comforting to talk to people who have been through what you've been through, that kind of thing. But the most important thing she's gotten from it?
辛迪对我说的有一件事真的让我感到意外。我们当时在谈论，自从她父亲去世后，她在网上联系上了一个社区，里面都是因新冠失去亲人的家庭成员。我问她别人说了什么对她有帮助，我以为她会说，与那些经历过相同痛苦的人交谈会让人感到安慰，诸如此类。但她从中得到的最重要的事情是什么呢？
I think some validation in the anger when you're surrounded by still some denial.
我认为当周围仍然充斥着否认声音时，这是对愤怒的一种证实。
People who say that the disease isn't that serious.
有些人说这种疾病没那么严重。
Yeah, or that masks don't really work.
是的，或者说口罩其实没用。
After her father got sick, Cindy says the car dealership where he worked told him that one of his co-workers had tested positive eight days before.
她父亲生病后，辛迪说，他工作的那家汽车经销商告诉他，他的一位同事在八天前检测结果呈阳性。
So you're angry at his employers.
所以你对他的雇主感到愤怒。
Oh, absolutely.
哦，当然。
And then you're angry at the government in general, the way it was handled.
然后你对政府整体的处理方式感到愤怒。
The fact that we still have a functioning television in our house is probably a miracle, because the number of times that I was ready to throw something when the occupant of the White House would talk about how this is no big deal, it's going to go away. Because we clearly knew that that wasn't true. And after my dad got sick and then died, I was just so angry. It's like, we knew what we needed to do. We could have done something in this country.
我们家里还能有一台正常运作的电视简直是个奇迹，因为当白宫的住户谈论这根本没什么大不了、很快就会过去的时候，我有多少次准备砸东西。因为我们清楚地知道那不是事实。我父亲生病去世后，我真是太愤怒了。这就好像，我们明明知道需要做什么。我们本可以在这个国家做些什么的。
Have you heard Joe Biden talk about the empty chair?
你听过乔·拜登谈论那把空椅子吗？
Yeah, it was actually the final debate. My dad's date of death is October 20th. And the last debate was October 22nd. And I had heard that line. I've heard him use it before. And I know that's a part of-- kind of like one of the things maybe from the stump speech, sort of thing.
是的，其实是在最后一场辩论中。我父亲的去世日期是 10 月 20 日。最后一场辩论是 10 月 22 日。我听说过那句台词。我以前听他用过。我知道那是我竞选演讲的一部分，类似那种东西。
Right, it's one of those things he said a million times.
没错，那是他说过一百万遍的东西之一。
Right, he said it a million times. And then, I'm sitting on the couch. And he looks at the camera, and he talks about it again after my dad died. And it truly felt like, oh, right, this is me now. This is my Thanksgiving. This is my Christmas. This is my son's 16th birthday. And somehow, even though I knew he had said that line hundreds of times before, I felt like he was looking through the television, straight at me. I felt like he was looking at our whole family. And I felt like he was looking at all of us, all of the other-- at the time, it was only, like, 200,000 families.
对，他说过一百万遍。然后，我坐在沙发上。他看着摄像机，在我父亲去世后又谈到了这一点。它真的感觉像是，噢，对了，现在是我了。这就是我的感恩节。这就是我的圣诞节。这就是我儿子 16 岁的生日。不知何故，尽管我知道他以前已经说过几百遍那句台词，我感觉他透过电视在直接看着我。我觉得他在看着我们全家。我觉得他在看着我们所有人，所有其他的——当时，大概只有 20 万个家庭。
Just three months later, of course, the numbers doubled. It's such a simple thing to acknowledge the loss that's all around us. Today, on our program, with the new president in office, one year after the first coronavirus case was found in the United States-- it was in Seattle, January 21st of last year-- here are stories about some of the things that have been lost this past year, things we do not usually think about as part of that empty chair. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
当然，仅仅三个月后，这个数字就翻了一番。承认我们周围的损失是一件如此简单的事情。今天在我们的节目中，随着新总统上任，在全美发现首例新冠病例一周年之际——那是去年 1 月 21 日在西雅图——这里有一些故事，讲述了过去一年中失去的一些东西，那些我们通常不会想到是那把“空椅子”一部分的事情。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Cops and Robbers. So what do you say exactly about what was lost two weeks ago on January 6th, when rioters stormed the Capitol building? When reporter Emmanuel Felton watched that day, out of all the footage he saw, one video stood out to him. You might have seen this one. It's of a single Black officer. We'd all later find his name, Eugene Goodman. And in the video, he's backing up a staircase, holding off a mob of rioters with a tiny telescoping baton.
第一幕，警察与强盗。那么，关于两周前 1 月 6 日暴徒冲进国会大厦时失去的东西，你究竟怎么说？当记者伊曼纽尔·费尔顿那天观看直播时，在他看到的所有画面中，有一个视频格外引人注目。你可能也看过这个。画面中是一名黑人警官。后来我们都知道了他的名字，尤金·古德曼。视频里，他正退后上楼梯，用一根小小的伸缩警棍挡住了一群暴徒。
[SHOUTING]
[叫喊声]
That gave Emmanuel the idea. He wanted to hear what the day was like for Black Capitol police officers, who faced off with this mostly white mob, a mob that showed up to the Capitol with Confederate flags and other symbols of white supremacy. What did they think about what happened? Eventually, he got a few of these officers on the phone, and they shared an insider account that is really unlike anything we've heard from the Capitol so far. Some of their experience, of course, was the same as white officers.
这给了伊曼纽尔灵感。他想了解那天对于那些面对这群大多是白人的暴徒的黑人国会警官来说是什么样的，这群暴徒带着邦联旗和其他白人至上主义的标志来到国会。他们对所发生的事情怎么想？最终，他联系上了几位这样的警官，他们分享了一段至今我们在国会事件中听到的完全不同的内部叙述。当然，他们的一些经历与白人警官是相同的。
But as you'll hear, some of it was very different. Emmanuel put together this next story from an interview with one of those Black officers. The Capitol Police officers, their job is to protect the Capitol grounds and members of Congress. Because they're not allowed to talk to the press, we needed to disguise this officer's identity. And so, we had an actor copy his voice as closely as possible. A quick warning also-- this story contains a racial slur. Here's Emmanuel.
但正如你将听到的，其中一些是非常不同的。伊曼纽尔从对其中一位黑人警官的采访中整理出了接下来的这个故事。国会警察的工作是保护国会大厦场地和国会议员。因为他们不允许接受媒体采访，我们需要掩盖这位警官的身份。所以，我们让一位演员尽可能地模仿他的声音。同样有一个快速警告——这个故事包含种族歧视用语。这是伊曼纽尔的报道。
The officer, who I'm calling Officer Jones, was the person almost everyone told me I just had to talk to. Jones is warm and outgoing as hell. At one point, he told me his love language is words of affirmation. He has a lot of feelings about his job. I talked to him on Friday, just two days after the attack. He was a little stunned, still processing everything that had happened, and nursing some injuries.
这位我称之为琼斯警官的人，是每个人都告诉我一定要谈谈的人。琼斯非常热情、随和。有一次，他告诉我他的“爱的语言”是言语鼓励。他对自己的工作很有感触。我在周五，也就是袭击发生的仅仅两天后和他谈过。他当时有点震惊，还在消化发生的一切，并处理着一些伤口。
Just scrapes, cuts, bruises, bloody knuckles. I got me some work in, I tell you that.
只是一些擦伤、割伤、瘀伤、满是鲜血的指关节。我确实干了一场硬仗，我告诉你们。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But I did see two dead bodies. Three, if you include my co-worker. But he wasn't dead at the time. I've never been in a war. I'm not a veteran, but I can imagine that's what the fuck war looks like.
但我确实看到了两具尸体。如果算上我的同事，是三个。但他当时还没死。我从未上过战场。我不是退伍军人，但我可以想象那特么就是战争的样子。
Yeah.
是的。
I can imagine that, so.
我可以想象，所以。
The day hadn't started that way at all. That morning, he was posted on the east side of the Capitol building.
那天根本不是那样开始的。那天早上，他被派往国会大厦东侧。
A friend of mine screenshotted me an Instagram story saying, we're breaching the Capitol today, guys. I hope you're all ready.
我的一个朋友截屏发给我一个 Instagram 快拍说：“伙计们，今天我们要攻破国会大厦。希望你们都准备好了。”
Officer Jones thinks it was from the Proud Boys.
琼斯警官认为那来自“骄傲男孩”。
And I'm like, wait, what? I laughed at it, and I was like, please. They ain't coming in here. Everybody say that. [LAUGHS]
然后我心想，等等，什么？我笑了笑，我说，拜托。他们才进不来这里。每个人都这么说。[笑声]
Of course, we know by now that's exactly what happened. Not long after 1:00, he says people were coming from everywhere.
当然，现在我们知道那正是发生的事情。下午 1 点过后没多久，他说人们从四面八方涌来。
And then, over the radio, they called out that they breached the first fence line or security. It was like, wait a minute. All right, guys. This is going to get real.
然后，无线电里呼叫说他们攻破了第一道防线或安保。当时就像是，等等，伙计们。好吧，伙计们。这要动真格的了。
He raced over to the west side of the Capitol, the side that faces the mall where the stage was set up for inauguration, and joined the police line as they tried to beat back the crowd with their fists and batons, pepper spraying them and yelling, "Get back! Get back!"
他冲向国会西侧，那一面正对着广场，舞台在那里搭建好了准备举行就职典礼，他加入了警察防线，他们试图用拳头和警棍击退人群，向他们喷洒胡椒喷雾，并大喊：“退后！退后！”
Have you ever been in a fight like that?
你经历过那样的战斗吗？
No, not like that. No way. These people were deranged, and they were determined. I've played video games before. Well, you know, zombie games-- Resident Evil, Call of Duty. And the zombies are just coming after you, and you're just out there. I guess that's what I could relate it to-- Call of Duty zombies. And the further you go, the more and more zombies just coming. You're just running, running, running. And they wouldn't stop. You're seeing they're getting their heads cracked with these batons, and we're spraying them, and they don't care! It was insane.
没有，从没像那样过。不可能。这些人疯了，而且他们很有决心。我以前玩过电子游戏。嗯，你知道，僵尸游戏——《生化危机》、《使命召唤》。僵尸不断朝你涌来，而你就站在那里。我想我可以把它联系起来——《使命召唤》里的僵尸。你走得越远，涌来的僵尸就越多。你就一直跑、跑、跑。他们就是不停下。你看到他们的头被警棍打爆，我们向他们喷射，但他们不在乎！这简直疯了。
Once the rioters broke into the Capitol around 2:00, Officer Jones rushed inside to try and help out. He wasn't following any instructions because there weren't any. He realized that as he listened into his radio.
下午 2 点左右暴徒闯入国会后，琼斯警官冲进去试图帮忙。他没有遵循任何指示，因为根本没有指示。当他收听无线电时，他意识到了这一点。
The Department was attempting to come up with a plan-- attempting to come up with a plan because that was said on the radio, "We need to come up with a plan."
部门试图制定一个计划——试图制定一个计划，因为无线电里就是这么说的：“我们需要制定一个计划。”
Whoa. [LAUGHS]
哇。[笑声]
I was thinking to myself, wait, why don't we have one already?
我心想，等等，为什么我们现在还没有一个计划？
So the officers came up with their own strategy. They linked up in teams of two and ran around the building, responding to distress calls coming in over the radio. Priority calls, which meant everyone stopped and listened. They were pouring in.
于是警官们自己制定了策略。他们两人一组联手在楼内奔跑，响应无线电中传来的求救呼叫。优先呼叫，这意味着每个人都要停下来听。它们源源不断地涌入。
So when you're used to hearing priority maybe once every two or three days and you're hearing it once every 30 seconds-- priority, we have an officer down. Priority, we have an officer trapped, surrounded by protesters. Priority, we have a person having a medical emergency. We need DC Fire to this location. Priority, they just breached the windows. Priority, they're breaking the glass. Priority, they're headed up to the House chamber. Priority, shots fired. And you're thinking, what in the hell is happening?
所以，当你习惯了每两三天听到一次优先呼叫，而现在每 30 秒就听到一次——优先呼叫，有警官倒下。优先呼叫，有警官被困，被抗议者包围。优先呼叫，有人出现医疗急症。我们需要特区消防部门去这个地点。优先呼叫，他们刚打破了窗户。优先呼叫，他们在砸玻璃。优先呼叫，他们正前往众议院大厅。优先呼叫，枪声响起。你就在想，这特么到底在发生什么？
While responding to these distress calls, Officer Jones got into some really surprising and intense conversations with the rioters, like when he and his partner were responding to a call for help from a fellow officer and ran into a crowd of 30 or 40 rioters headed straight for an area full of injured cops.
在响应这些求救呼叫时，琼斯警官与暴徒进行了一些非常令人惊讶且激烈的对话，就像当他和搭档响应一名同事的求救呼叫时，撞见了一群 30 到 40 名正径直冲向一个充满受伤警察区域的暴徒。
I sent the guy I was with-- I told him to go ahead and respond to the other call, and I'll stand here and I'll hold this hallway. And I took them all by myself. I made an impassioned plea to them. I said, "Listen. You have the nerve to be holding a Blue Lives Matter flag, and you are out there fucking us up. Please go the fuck home. You don't care about us. How can you care about us, and you're doing this to us? We got dozens of cops incapacitated and hurt now."
我让和我在一起的那个人——我让他继续去响应另一个呼叫，我一个人站在那里守住走廊。我一个人面对他们所有人。我向他们发出了激烈的恳求。我说：“听着。你们居然有脸拿着‘蓝命也是命’的旗帜，而你们却在外面特么地攻击我们。请特么回家吧。你们根本不在乎我们。如果你们正在对我们做这种事，你们怎么可能在乎我们？我们现在有几十名警察失去了战斗能力，受了伤。”
And when I said that, a lot of them stopped and paused and was like, wait, y'all got cops down? How many cops are down? And they looked like they had a moment of like, holy fuck. And then, they snapped back out of it. And it was like, hey, guys. Man, we're doing this for you. And then, one of the guys, it was a group of, like, seven people walked by. And two of them in the back say, "Hey, listen, man. I know what you're going through," and he pulled out his badge.
当我那样说时，他们中很多人停了下来，愣住了，好像在说：等等，你们有警察倒下了？有多少警察倒下了？他们看起来好像有一瞬间，像是，天哪。然后，他们又回过神来。就像是：嘿，伙计们。我们要为你们做这件事。然后，其中一个人，是一个七人小组走过。后面两个人说：“嘿，听着，伙计。我知道你正在经历什么，”然后他拿出了他的徽章。
A police badge.
警察徽章。
And the other guy had his badge. I was like, wait, you got to be kidding. And I wanted to go up and snatch it. I wanted to find out who the fuck they were. And me, I'm the only Black dude standing in front of them.
另一个人也有他的徽章。我心想，等等，你们在开玩笑吧。我真想冲上去把它抢过来。我想查清楚他们特么的是谁。而我，是站在他们面前唯一的黑人。
Yeah. So what did they do?
是的。那他们做了什么？
They looked at me. They yelled at me. They were yelling at me. And I would not let them go past. They all want to go past me? I'm going to beat all your asses. One by one, I'm going to deck all of y'all. Come on. And that's when one of the guys that was a cop said, "Hey, man, we're going to stand here with you." I was like, "No, get the fuck out of my building." He was like, "This is our building." And I was like, "This is my goddamn building. I'm in charge here. Get the fuck out." And that's when I started losing my temper even more. I mean, I got tears streaming down my face.
他们看着我。他们对我大喊大叫。他们正在对我大喊。我不让他们过去。他们都想越过我？我要把你们所有人的屁股都踢一遍。一个接一个，我要把你们所有人都打倒。来吧。就在那时，那个警察之一说：“嘿，伙计，我们要和你站在一起。”我当时说：“不，特么的滚出我的大楼。”他说：“这是我们的大楼。”我说：“这是我该死的大楼。我在这里负责。特么的滚出去。”就在那时我更加火冒三丈。我的意思是，我眼泪夺眶而出。
Later that day, when he was even more drained, he had another confrontation, this one about politics. It happened near the rotunda when Officer Jones was trying to protect a critical hallway. There was something like 70 of them this time. The attackers he was facing off with started justifying what they were doing. "Listen," they told him. "We can't let them overtake our democracy. We're stopping this deal, man."
那天晚些时候，当他更加精疲力竭时，他发生了另一次对峙，这次是关于政治的。这发生在圆形大厅附近，当时琼斯警官正试图保护一条关键的走廊。这次大概有 70 多个人。他面对的袭击者开始为他们的所作所为辩解。“听着，”他们对他说道，“我们不能让他们推翻我们的民主。我们要阻止这笔交易，伙计。”
Then I started-- actually, I got baited into a conversation. I didn't get baited because I wanted to fucking engage him. And the guy was telling me. I was like, "Yeah, I voted for Joe Biden. So the fuck what?" I was like, "What? Do I not matter? Am I a liar? I voted for Joe Biden. So the fuck what? So tell me I don't fucking matter." I was like, "What? Oh, I gotta agree with you? I gotta agree with you? If I don't, what? You're going to kill me?"
然后我开始——实际上，我被诱导进了一场谈话。我并没有被诱导，因为我想特么地与他交谈。那家伙正在告诉我。我说：“是的，我投票给了乔·拜登。那又特么怎么样？”我说：“什么？我不重要吗？我是个骗子吗？我投票给了乔·拜登。那又特么怎么样？所以告诉我我不特么重要。”我说：“什么？哦，我必须同意你？我必须同意你？如果我不呢，什么？你要杀了我？”
I think that so much of Trump and his supporters' anger and inability to accept their loss in the 2020 election boils down to the idea that Black votes just shouldn't count. The president has continuously attacked Black voters. He has claimed that there was widespread fraud in a number of cities with large Black populations, cities like Atlanta, Detroit, Philadelphia, and he has demanded that thousands of votes be thrown out because of it. But this crowd was a lot more, mm, direct.
我认为特朗普及其支持者很大一部分的愤怒和无法接受在 2020 年选举中失败的现实，归结于黑人选票本就不该被计算这一想法。总统不断攻击黑人选民。他声称在许多黑人人口众多的城市，如亚特兰大、底特律、费城，存在广泛的舞弊行为，并因此要求作废成千上万张选票。但这群人要直接得多，嗯，直接得多。
They were lighting into me. "Oh, this nigga voted for Joe Biden." And he yelled it to his crowd, the crowd, and they booed.
他们正在辱骂我。“哦，这个黑鬼投票给了乔·拜登。”他对着他的那群人，那群人，大喊出来，他们发出了嘘声。
Eventually, reinforcements from other police departments arrived to help clear out the building. It was a little before 5:00 when things finally calmed down enough that officers were told to take a few seconds to send an "I'm OK" text to loved ones. When Jones looked down at his phone, he had something like 70 text messages and over 30 missed calls. Not long after that, he finally got a chance to sit down, catch his breath, and take it all in.
最终，来自其他警察部门的增援赶到，帮助清空了大楼。接近下午 5 点时，局势终于平静下来，指挥部通知警官们花几秒钟给亲人发一条“我没事”的短信。当琼斯低头看手机时，他有 70 多条短信和 30 多个未接来电。那之后没多久，他终于有机会坐下来，喘口气，平复一下心情。
I didn't even think about race until we got everybody out. And I sat down with one of my buddies, and tears just started streaming down my face. Now, obviously, all the commotion has ended, so it's just law enforcement in there and FBI suits and all these suits walking around. Everybody-- you know, the important people show up once all the fucking mess is done.
直到我们把每个人都带出去，我都没想过种族问题。我和我的一个哥们坐下来，眼泪顺着我的脸流了下来。现在很明显，所有的骚动都已经结束，所以里面只有执法人员、FBI 的西装革履的人，所有这些西装人在走来走去。每个人——你知道，重要人物总是等到所有的特么乱子结束后才出现。
Right.
没错。
And I'm just sitting there, covered in fucking tear gas and OC spray. And I'm looking at my buddy. He put his arm around me, another Black guy. And I was like-- I was like, you got-- look at him, look at him. They're just sitting there, smiling, sitting there, hand shaking each other.
我坐在那里，浑身都是特么催泪瓦斯和辣椒喷雾。我看着我的哥们。他把手臂搭在我肩膀上，另一个黑人小伙。我说——我说，你看他，看他。他们只是坐在那里，微笑，坐在那里，互相握手。
He means the FBI guys and other law enforcement.
他指的是 FBI 的那些人和其他的执法人员。
What the fuck are you smiling about? What the fuck are you smiling about? And I'm furious. And that's when I said, "I'm so sick and tired of this shit. These were racist-ass terrorists!" And I'm screaming. I'm in the rotunda, and it echoes. So it was loud as shit. Everybody stopped, and they turned around and looked at me. And I was like, "What the fuck are y'all looking at? Nobody should be OK. We just fought for five fucking hours with some fucking racist terrorists." I said, "I got called a nigger 15 times, man."
你们在特么笑什么？你们在特么笑什么？我简直怒不可遏。就在那时我说：“我真是受够了这些破事。这些都是种族主义恐怖分子！”我在大喊。我在圆形大厅里，声音有回音。所以这声音大得要命。每个人都停下来，转过头看着我。我说：“你们特么在看什么？没人应该觉得还好。我们刚刚和一些特么的种族主义恐怖分子搏斗了整整五个特么小时。”我说：“我被叫了 15 次‘黑鬼’，伙计。”
Yeah. Fuck, yeah. I'm trying to imagine as a Black man what it was like, having the N-word hurled at you, seeing that kind of ugly racism.
是的。妈的，是的。我试着以一个黑人的身份去想象那是什么样的，听到那种肮脏的种族主义攻击，被羞辱。
It broke my heart. Like I said, that's why I had my breakdown in the rotunda. And I just sat there and I cried. I cried. I cried for about 15 minutes, and I just let it out. I was done. I was mentally exhausted. I was physically exhausted. And I didn't have anything left to give. And it just hurts so much. And then I looked at my buddy. And I remember, I said, "Is this fucking America, yo? What are we doing?" I was like, what is happening?
这让我心碎。就像我说的，这就是为什么我在圆形大厅里崩溃了。我只是坐在那里，哭。我哭了。我哭了大概 15 分钟，我只是把情绪发泄了出来。我受够了。我精神上精疲力竭。我体力上也透支了。我什么都没有了。这真的很伤人。然后我看着我的哥们。我记得我说：“这是特么的美国吗？我们在做什么？”我心想，到底发生了什么？
I've been thinking a lot about what January 6th says about America. When I think about that day, I remember the photos I saw early that morning of Black poll workers in Georgia bravely counting the runoff ballots in the middle of a pandemic and under threat from Trump supporters; how, that afternoon, I saw video of a Black officer, Eugene Goodman, protecting Mike Pence and lawmakers from the insurrectionists; and later that night, watching a video of Black Capitol staff cleaning up the mess the rioters left. Through all the attacks, everywhere I looked, it was Black people doing the job of making our democracy work.
我一直在思考 1 月 6 日对美国意味着什么。当我想到那天，我记得那天清晨看到的照片：佐治亚州的黑人计票员在疫情中、在特朗普支持者的威胁下勇敢地统计决选选票；那天下午，我看到尤金·古德曼警官保护迈克·彭斯和议员免受暴徒袭击的视频；以及当天晚上，看到黑人国会工作人员清理暴徒留下的烂摊子的视频。经历了所有的袭击，无论我看向哪里，都是黑人在做着让我们的民主正常运转的工作。
It was a job Officer Jones continued to do the day after the attack. He went straight back to work. With continuing threats, the Capitol Police have had to work around the clock. 16-hour days have become the norm. He's had just one day off in the two weeks between January 6th and Inauguration. I talked to him a few days before.
这是琼斯警官在袭击发生后第二天继续做的工作。他直接回去工作了。由于持续的威胁，国会警察不得不日以继夜地工作。每天工作 16 个小时已成为常态。在 1 月 6 日到就职典礼之间的两周里，他只休息了一天。我在几天前和他谈过。
So you're back at work now. What does it feel like to be at the Capitol today?
所以你现在回去工作了。今天在国会大厦是什么感觉？
You look around and you see all these soldiers here. You look around and you see unscalable razor wire fences around here. And as an officer who got his ass whooped a couple of days ago, you feel good. Hell yeah. Come back, try it again. We got help now. Try it again. So as an officer, I'm like, yeah. But as just a person, American citizen, Black man, you feel like, what the hell? Is this normal now? Is this what we got to do to prevent this from happening? It's-- man. It's-- ugh.
你环顾四周，看到这里所有的士兵。你环顾四周，看到周围设置了不可逾越的带刺铁丝网围栏。作为一名几天前刚被暴打一顿的警察，你感觉很好。妈的，是的。再来啊，再试一次。我们现在有援助了。再试一次。所以作为一个警察，我心想，是的。但作为一个普通人、美国公民、黑人，你心想，这到底是什么情况？这现在正常吗？为了防止这种情况再次发生，我们必须这样做吗？这——伙计。这——哎。
There's a long list somewhere of things we thought could never happen. And so many of them have been lost, struck off the list, disappeared in the last year. This was just the latest one. In my conversations with the officers, it felt like we were saying, sure, there are a lot of racists in America. But this? That they could storm the Capitol, that they could shut down our government, that left us in awe. That was new.
在某处有一份长长的名单，列着我们认为永远不可能发生的事情。在过去一年里，其中许多已经被划掉、消失了。这只是最新的一项。在我和警官们的谈话中，感觉我们都在说，当然，美国有很多种族主义者。但这个？他们竟然能冲击国会，他们竟然能让政府瘫痪，这让我们感到震惊。那是全新的体验。
Emmanuel Felton-- he writes about race and inequality for BuzzFeed News. He checked in with Officer Jones on Inauguration Day this week. Officer Jones said he was glad they were going to inaugurate the president that the rioters did not want to see inaugurated in public, in their faces, he said.
伊曼纽尔·费尔顿——他为 BuzzFeed News 报道种族和不平等问题。本周就职典礼那天，他联系了琼斯警官。琼斯警官说，他很高兴他们将为那位暴徒们不想见到的总统举行就职典礼，在公众面前，在他们脸上举行，他说。
But when the actual day came, he did not get to enjoy it himself. He didn't see any of the speeches or the performances. He was working on the east side of the building, far from the action. The actor whose voice you heard saying Officer Jones's words is Gbenga Akinagbe. You can see him in the upcoming FX Hulu series, The Old Man, with Jeff Bridges and John Lithgow.
但当真正的那一天到来时，他自己并没有享受到。他没有看到任何演讲或表演。他在大楼东侧工作，离现场很远。那个你听到的说出琼斯警官心声的演员是格本加·阿金纳格。你可以在即将上映的 FX Hulu 系列剧《老头子》中看到他和杰夫·布里吉斯与约翰·利思戈搭档演出。
Coming up, we share something with you that you need, that is missing from your life, that you may not even have noticed how much you need this. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，我们将与你分享一件你需要的、你生活中缺失的、甚至可能都没有注意到你有多需要它的东西。就在芝加哥公共广播的节目稍后继续，一分钟后。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Empty Chair. We have stories about things that have been lost this past year, things that seemed worth noting, as we head into whatever new chapter is going to unfold this year. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, 50 Shades of Shade.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是《空椅子》。我们讲述了过去一年失去的一些故事，那些在进入今年即将展开的新篇章时值得注意的事情。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，阴影的 50 道光影。
So here is something else that we have all lost since the pandemic. It almost feels too small to mention, but really, I think, is pretty significant. Rachel Connolly noticed this. She's a writer in London. Our producer Lilly Sullivan talked to her.
那么，还有一件事是我们自疫情以来都失去了的。提到它感觉有点太小了，但真的，我认为是非常重要的。瑞秋·康诺利注意到了这一点。她是伦敦的一名作家。我们的制作人莉莉·沙利文采访了她。
To understand why this thing Rachel's missing matters so much, let's start with a little story about two brothers.
要理解为什么瑞秋错过的这件事如此重要，让我们从一个关于两兄弟的小故事开始。
OK, fab. So we just call them Frank and Stephen. They're slightly different ages. Frank is the older brother, and he's kind of shorter, less handsome. Stephen's kind of the handsome brother. But Frank is kind of more gregarious and charming and this kind of really funny guy. So they both are kind of attractive in different ways.
好的，太棒了。我们就叫他们弗兰克和斯蒂芬吧。他们的年龄略有不同。弗兰克是哥哥，他有点矮，没那么帅。斯蒂芬是比较帅的那个弟弟。但弗兰克更合群、更有魅力，是一个非常风趣的人。所以他们以不同的方式都挺有吸引力的。
This happened at the beginning of the pandemic. The brothers had moved back to their hometown for lockdown in a kind of surreal second adolescence, back with their parents, social distance hanging with people they'd kind of known in high school. Frank and Stephen-- not their real names-- are in their early 20s. They'd spent the day drinking outside with someone they'd grown up with.
这件事发生在疫情初期。两兄弟搬回了家乡封锁，经历了一种超现实的“第二次青春期”，和父母住在一起，与他们在高中认识的人保持社交距离地聚会。弗兰克和斯蒂芬——不是他们的真实姓名——才 20 多岁。他们花了一整天在外面和从小一起长大的人喝酒。
And she's called Beth. And Frank, the less handsome but funny one, he's always had a thing for Beth. And he's kind of like, you know what? I've been meaning to do this for years. This night is going to be our night. And he said this to Stephen. Like, I think this is going to be the night it finally happens. And so, they were drinking all day. And Frank just got drunker and drunker and drunker because people do, do that when they want to do something, but don't want to kind of be responsible for doing it. They were kind of--
她叫贝丝。而弗兰克，那个不那么帅但很有趣的家伙，一直对贝丝有好感。他心想，你知道吗？我多年来一直想做这件事。今晚就是我们的夜晚。他对斯蒂芬说了。就像，我觉得今晚终于要实现了。所以，他们喝了一整天的酒。弗兰克变得越来越醉，因为人们在想做某事却又不想承担责任时，就会这样做。他们有点——
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Yep. So he got by the end of the day totally plastered, slurring his words, just telling the same story over and over again. And Stephen was like, I'm just going to do the nice thing here and just bring you back, Frank. You're too drunk, and it doesn't look good.
是的。所以在一天结束时，他已经醉得一塌糊涂，说话含糊不清，只是不停地重复讲同一个故事。斯蒂芬心想，我在这里做好事，带你回家吧，弗兰克。你太醉了，这看起来不好看。
Stephen tells Beth, "I'm going to be a good brother here." He takes Frank home and puts him to bed.
斯蒂芬告诉贝丝：“我要做个好兄弟。”他把弗兰克带回家，送他上床休息。
Which is all very charitable-seeming. But once he had done this, he then went back to Beth's house-- cycled back as well, not even walked. And guess what happens next?
这看起来非常慷慨。但一旦他做了这件事，他又骑车回到贝丝家——甚至是骑车回来的，都没走路。你猜接下来发生了什么？
Sex. Sex is what happened next between Beth and Stephen, the younger brother, the more handsome but less funny brother, who had not liked Beth since childhood. This is what we used to call gossip. It's the way conversation used to be before the pandemic took it away from us.
性。发生的事情就是贝丝和斯蒂芬——那个弟弟，那个更帅但不那么风趣的弟弟，那个从小就不喜欢贝丝的家伙——之间发生了性关系。这就是我们以前所说的“八卦”。在疫情夺走它之前，这曾是交谈的方式。
I found Rachel because she wrote an essay about how she suddenly noticed its absence. She put her finger on this thing that I've been feeling, too. She wrote, "This was the year when everything happened and nothing happened. And I quickly got bored of talking about the news-- almost always bad-- or asking people what they'd been up to-- almost always nothing."
我找到了瑞秋，因为她写了一篇文章，讲述了她突然注意到它的缺失。她指出了我也一直感受到的那种东西。她写道：“这是万事发生却又什么都没发生的一年。我很快就厌倦了谈论新闻——几乎总是坏消息——或者问别人在做什么——几乎总是无所事事。”
Just Zoom calls with the same people to have essentially the same conversation, which was like, what have you done today? How is lockdown? Everyone safe? And then it would be like, so what's going on? And everyone would be like, nothing, actually, really. Not really much on.
只是和同样的人进行 Zoom 通话，基本上说着同样的对话，就像：“你今天做了什么？封锁怎么样？大家安全吗？”然后就变成了：“那么，发生了什么？”每个人都会说：“没什么，真的。真的没发生什么事。”
Oh, that's so true, though, that moment when people are like, "So what's new?" And you're like, "Nothing."
哦，那真是太真实了，当人们问：“那么有什么新鲜事？”而你回答：“没什么。”
Yeah.
是的。
The thing about this story, Rachel doesn't even know these people.
关于这个故事的事，瑞秋甚至不认识这些人。
Yep, no.
是的，没有。
Not at all.
根本不认识。
No.
没有。
She thinks she maybe met one of the brothers at a party once. She just heard this story from a friend of hers. He's the one who knows Frank and Stephen. The best kind of gossip, of course, is about people you know. But she didn't have that. And she was so hungry for it. It turns out in a pinch-- or in a pandemic-- strangers will do.
她认为她可能在聚会上见过其中一个兄弟一次。她只是从她的一个朋友那里听说了这个故事。是他认识弗兰克和斯蒂芬。当然，最好的八卦是关于你认识的人的。但她没有。她太渴望了。事实证明，在紧要关头——或是在疫情期间——陌生人也可以凑合。
You can't sleep with the person your brother likes. You just, like--
你不能和你哥哥喜欢的女孩子睡觉。你只是，就像——
Do you think it's so bad? I'm not sure. I kind of think it's one of those drunk things where it's like, if it's someone's liked them from a teenager, I'm like, do they even like them, or is it just like-- is this-- is it just someone who's here and has always been here?
你觉得那真的很糟糕吗？我不确定。我有点觉得那是那种酒后冲动的事情，就像，如果这是某人从青少年时期就喜欢的人，我想，他们真的喜欢她吗，还是只是——这——这只是一个在这儿而且一直都在这儿的人？
Oh my god.
我的天。
Yeah.
是的。
Rachel and I are both living without kids or extended family. We haven't lost our jobs. Neither we nor our loved ones got very sick. I recognize how dumb our concerns are compared to what so many people's lives have been, but we both noticed a thing that, over the course of the pandemic, had kind of drifted away while we weren't paying attention-- the ability to socialize like a normal person. Talking, it turns out, is like a muscle. And when you don't use it much for months on end, it can atrophy. Rachel remembers the first time she went out to meet up with more than one person.
我和瑞秋都没有孩子或大家庭。我们没有失业。我们和我们的亲人都没有病得太重。我意识到与许多人的生活相比，我们的烦恼有多蠢，但我们都注意到了一件事：在疫情期间，当我不注意的时候，它悄悄溜走了——那种像个正常人一样社交的能力。事实证明，谈话就像一块肌肉。当你连续几个月不怎么使用它时，它就会萎缩。瑞秋还记得她第一次出去见不止一个人的情形。
I was literally like-- the next day, I felt like I had run a marathon or had done this extraordinary feat of endurance when it was just having a conversation with more than one person for a couple of hours. It was like a job. You have to really focus on what you're saying. You have to focus on your body language.
我简直觉得——第二天，我感觉自己像跑了一场马拉松，或者完成了一项非凡的耐力壮举，而实际上只是和不止一个人交谈了几个小时。这就像一份工作。你必须真正专注于你所说的话。你必须专注于你的肢体语言。
I felt this also. Friends would get in touch and want to go for a walk. I'm like, mm, it sounds awkward. I'll see you after the pandemic. It's not that I don't want to see people. There's just no fuel for conversation. Stuff from before the pandemic is too old to talk about now. So what are you supposed to talk about when there are no situations?
我也感觉到了。朋友们会联系我想出去走走。我心想，嗯，听起来有点尴尬。我疫情后再见你。并不是我不想见人。只是谈话没有燃料了。疫情之前的事情现在谈论起来太老旧了。那么当没有情况发生时，你应该谈论什么呢？
So Rachel started doing this thing that I thought was pretty brilliant. She started asking people, got any gossip about anyone? And it kind of worked. Conversation was easier when you were talking about the tailor who lied about her husband's death to avoid an uncomfortable conversation about a missing shirt, or the guy who'd hooked up with his roommate and it didn't work out, and should he move now?
所以瑞秋开始做我以为非常聪明的一件事。她开始问人们：有关于任何人的八卦吗？这居然奏效了。当你谈论那个为了避免谈论缺失的衬衫而对丈夫死讯撒谎的裁缝，或者那个和室友上床却没搞定而不知该不该搬走的家伙时，谈话变得容易多了。
I could talk your ear off about a friend of mine whose fiancé broke up with her during couple's therapy-- remote couple's therapy over Zoom. How my friend watched her fiancé dump her from their laptop screen, even though they were sitting side by side on their bed. This kind of talk, it wasn't exactly normal like before, but it was good enough, like pretty decent fake meat.
我可以滔滔不绝地跟你讲我的一位朋友，她的未婚夫在夫妻治疗期间——通过 Zoom 远程夫妻治疗——和她分手了。我朋友如何从笔记本电脑屏幕上看着她的未婚夫甩了她，尽管他们当时正并排坐在床上。这种谈话，虽然不像以前那样完全正常，但也还不错，就像某种体面的“人造肉”。
It's like that story about the two brothers. It delivers the thrill of being scandalized and that demented, little bond you feel when you huddle up with someone and judge people together. Clearly, the younger brother, Stephen, was wrong, the handsome snake. But also, Beth, they're brothers. Did you really have to do that? But actually, hold that thought.
就像那两个兄弟的故事。它带来了被丑闻震惊的快感，以及当你和某人挤在一起审判他人时感受到的那种疯狂的小小纽带。显然，弟弟斯蒂芬是错的，那个帅气的渣男。但还有，贝丝，那是兄弟俩。你真的必须那么做吗？但实际上，等一下。
There is more.
还有更多。
Here's the rest of the story. Frank, the funny one, he didn't know his brother had slept with Beth. And about a week later, he also sleeps with Beth, the crush he'd put dibs on back in, like, eighth grade. He was really excited about it.
故事的其余部分是这样的。弗兰克，那个有趣的哥哥，不知道他弟弟和贝丝睡了。大约一周后，他也和贝丝睡了——那个他从八年级开始就预定了的暗恋对象。他对此非常兴奋。
And he was sitting with a group of friends a few days after, kind of boasting they were going to have a lockdown thing and that this has finally happened. And then, one of these friends was like, oh, wait, but do you know about Stephen? I'm presuming you do. And Frank was like, what?
几天后他正和一群朋友坐在一起，吹嘘他们会有一个“封锁之恋”，而这件事终于发生了。然后，其中一个朋友说：哦，等等，但你知道斯蒂芬的事吗？我以为你知道。弗兰克就说：什么？
And then, yeah, it was broken to him by this, and also broken in front of a kind of group of people. And then, he kind of had to row back and be like, I wasn't serious about this. I didn't mean we were going to have a lockdown thing, which is obviously always-- it's always mortifying when you have been talking earnestly about something, and then it's revealed that you didn't have a piece of information that other people has.
然后，是的，这个消息被朋友揭开了，而且还是在一群人面前。他只好退缩说：我不是认真的。我没说我们会有“封锁之恋”，这显然总是——当你真诚地谈论某事，然后被揭露你缺乏别人掌握的信息时，总是令人羞愧的。
Completely, yeah.
完全是，是的。
Frank called Beth and told her the whole lockdown thing was off. He and his brother had a big falling out. And Beth was really sad because it turns out she actually liked Frank back the same way he liked her. The thing with Stephen was just a drunk hookup. Frank was the real thing.
弗兰克给贝丝打了电话，告诉她“封锁之恋”取消了。他和弟弟大吵了一架。贝丝非常难过，因为原来她确实也喜欢弗兰克，就像他喜欢她一样。和斯蒂芬的事情只是一次酒后乱性。弗兰克才是真爱。
Oh, really? She was like, we could have had a lockdown thing.
噢，真的吗？她就觉得：我们本可以有“封锁之恋”的。
Yeah, she was like, the lockdown thing is off the cards, but it shouldn't have been. That shouldn't have been the way it went, and I should have told him.
是的，她说：封锁之恋不再可能了，但这不应该发生的。事情不该那样发展，我应该告诉他的。
She was confiding all this in a friend, who we'll call Sarah, who then goes off and sleeps with Frank, even though Beth had just told Sarah how much she liked him.
她把这一切都向一个朋友倾诉，我们称她为萨拉，结果萨拉转头就和弗兰克睡了，尽管贝丝刚刚告诉萨拉她有多喜欢他。
I like that everyone behaved as a human does, which is, like, everyone is self-interested. People do do things out of a vengeance and spite. But that is just normal behavior. It's part of life. And I think when we were discussing different chapters of the story, one person would be totally appalled by the fact that someone would do something. And another person would be like, yeah, no, I would do that.
我喜欢每个人都表现得像个人一样，也就是说，每个人都是利己的。人们确实出于报复和恶意做事情。但那是正常的行为。这是生活的一部分。而且我认为当我们讨论故事的不同章节时，一个人会完全被某人竟然会做那种事而感到震惊。而另一个人会说：是的，不，我会那样做。
I'd kind of been dreading this interview, just like I dread talking to anyone these days. My social skills are rusty. I worried that we'd run out of things to talk about. I had actually postponed our call for a week because of that.
我本来很害怕这次采访，就像我现在害怕和任何人交谈一样。我的社交技能生锈了。我担心我们会没话题可聊。因为这个，我实际上把通话推迟了一周。
But it's really fun to talk with you about this, and I'm like, oh my God, I'm totally paying attention. I'm following everything she's saying. I'm relating.
但和你谈论这个真的很开心，我心想，天哪，我完全在关注。我正在跟上她说的每一件事。我产生了共鸣。
I'm operating successfully as a human.
我作为一个人类成功地运作着。
As a human, yeah. That was a joke. I understood that it's a joke. A lot of the times, I don't.
作为一个人类，是的。那是个玩笑。我理解那是个玩笑。很多时候，我理解不了。
My joke receptor was--
我的笑话接收器被——
It was very funny, and I enjoyed it.
那非常有趣，我很喜欢。
I did enjoy it. I realized it's one of the most fun conversations I've had in months. It's not about shit talking people. It's about the shit talking itself and the fact that we're doing it together.
我确实很喜欢。我意识到这是我几个月来参与的最有趣的对话之一。它不是关于说别人的坏话。它是关于说坏话这件事本身，以及我们在一起做这件事的事实。
I haven't even told you the last part of the story. Beth's mad at her friend Sarah for sleeping with the guy she liked. So she tells this other friend, Sarah's a slut. And then, that other friend turns around and tells Sarah, Beth called you a slut.
我甚至还没告诉你故事的最后一部分。贝丝因为萨拉和她喜欢的男人睡觉而生萨拉的气。所以她告诉了另一个朋友：萨拉是个荡妇。然后那个朋友转过身告诉萨拉：贝丝叫你荡妇。
This peripheral friend is like, well, I've now become part of this.
这个外围的朋友就像是：嗯，我现在成为这件事的一部分了。
She completely inserted herself into the thing.
她完全把自己插进了这件事里。
Actually, to me, this is the worst, is like inserting yourself in, just with no other--
实际上，对我来说，这是最糟糕的，就像把自己塞进去，没有任何其他理由——
Yeah, she didn't even sleep with anyone.
是的，她甚至没和任何人睡觉。
Yeah, she just was like, I had to tell her. But and also she didn't know when people snitch, they always do that thing of like-- everyone does this. They're always like, I simply felt she had to know. People are like--
是的，她只是觉得：我必须告诉她。而且她不知道当人们告密时，他们总是那样——每个人都这样做。他们总是说：我觉得她有权知道。人们总是——
That's so true. My principles compelled me to deliver the information. Duty bound.
太对了。我的原则驱使我传递这个信息。职责所在。
I wouldn't have said anything, but I felt I had to.
我本来不会说什么，但我觉得我必须说。
It's so true. I could actually see myself being the snitch in that situation. She had the right to know. It was her right. I could see myself doing that. Just inserting myself, like the worst character in it, too, when I have no stakes in it. Just needing to be--
太对了。我实际上能看到自己在那种情况下成为那个告密者。她有权知道。这是她的权利。我能看到自己那样做。仅仅是插入自己，就像里面最糟糕的角色，当我里面没有任何利害关系时。仅仅是需要成为——
I think the snitch is quite a controversial thing because the minute I heard about the snitch, I was like, how could she just doing that, like being that person? And then a couple other people were like, is it so bad? So you're the snitch.
我认为告密者是一个很有争议的角色，因为当我听到关于告密者时，我心想：她怎么能那么做，就像成为那样的人？然后其他几个人就说：有那么糟糕吗？所以你就是那个告密者。
OK, so that's the end. So who's right? Who's wrong? Do we care? We do.
好吧，这就是结尾。所以谁是对的？谁是错的？我们在乎吗？我们在乎。
Lilly Sullivan is a producer on our show. For more gossip and thoughts about gossip, you can find Rachel Connolly's essay that inspired this story in Hazlitt. That's where it first came out. It is pretty delightful. It is called "The Year in Gossip."
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制作人。想了解更多关于八卦的思考，你可以在《Hazlitt》杂志中找到启发了这个故事的瑞秋·康诺利的文章。那是它首次发表的地方。它非常令人愉悦。题目叫《八卦的一年》。
Act Three, There's a German Word for That. So one thing that we've lost this past year is something big, something we all took for granted, I think-- something kind of frightening in its implications. And that's the idea that we could come out of a national election and agree that it was legit and agree on who won. You're either on one side of this or the other. Either you think the man in the White House today won the election fair and square, or you don't.
第三幕，德语里有个词是形容这个的。那么，过去一年我们失去的一件事是件大事，是我们都认为理所当然的事情，我想——在某种程度上，其影响有些令人恐惧。那就是：我们可以在全国大选后达成一致，认为它是合法的，并对谁赢了达成共识。你要么站在这一边，要么在那一边。要么你认为今天在白宫的人是公平公正地赢得了选举，要么你就不这么认为。
To state it clearly and unambiguously, I and the producers of this radio program side with all the people out there who do not think the election was stolen-- including, apparently, now former Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell, who said that people who believe otherwise were fed lies.
明确且毫不含糊地说，我和这个广播节目的制作人们站在所有认为选举没有被窃取的人这一边——包括显然现在是前参议院多数党领袖的米奇·麦康奈尔，他说那些认为不然的人是被喂了谎言。
But right now, millions of people believe that the wrong guy is in the White House. A third of all voters believe there was widespread fraud, which is remarkable, right? Back in November, a journalist in Germany, Jochen Bittner, was watching this unfold, seeing the fake evidence that was showing up under the hashtag, #stopthesteal, reading the president's tweets about supposed election fraud.
但现在，数以百万计的人认为入主白宫的人搞错了。三分之一的选民认为存在广泛的舞弊，这很引人注目，对吧？早在 11 月，德国记者约亨·比特纳就在观察这一切，看着标签 #stopthesteal 下出现的虚假证据，读着总统关于所谓选举舞弊的推文。
And for some reason, what sprang to my mind was, then, the memory of the dolchstosslegende, or the stab in the back myth--
出于某种原因，当时我脑海中闪现的是关于“背后捅刀传说”的记忆——
The stab in the back myth.
“背后捅刀传说”。
--that I learned about in school. I mean, more or less, every German would know the stab in the back myth because it was such a potent lie in German history.
——我在学校里学到的那个。我的意思是，几乎每个德国人都知道“背后捅刀传说”，因为它在德国历史上是一个如此强大的谎言。
Stop the steal is about losing an election. The stab in the back myth is about losing an entire war, namely World War I. But there are parallels between the two lies and the way they took hold that are unsettling. The history goes like this. Basically, there came a point in 1918. The United States had entered the war. Germans suffered defeats. It was clear to everybody that Germany was going to lose.
“停止窃取”是关于输掉一场选举。“背后捅刀传说”是关于输掉整场战争，即第一次世界大战。但这两个谎言以及它们扎根的方式之间存在着令人不安的平行之处。历史是这样的。基本上，1918 年出现了一个转折点。美国加入了战争。德国遭受了失败。每个人都很清楚德国要输了。
In fact, Navy sailors refused to head out to be killed in what they saw as suicide missions in a war that was doomed. Within Germany, lots of the population was against it. And so, in 1918, the Germans surrendered. The German emperor, Kaiser Wilhelm II, abdicated the throne, fled the country. Germany became a democracy for the first time.
事实上，海军水兵拒绝出海，因为他们不想在一场注定失败的战争中送死。在德国国内，很多人反对战争。因此，1918 年，德国投降了。德国皇帝威廉二世退位，逃离了国家。德国第一次成为民主国家。
But right away, starting in 1918-- coincidentally, also a global pandemic going on right then, the 1918 flu. 50 million died. Right then, starting in 1918, right-wing politicians and newspapers started pushing this lie, a kind of steady, angry drumbeat of coverage, saying that, in fact, they could have won the war if Jews and Social Democrats and leftists hadn't stabbed the country in the back by forcing Germany to surrender.
但随即，从 1918 年开始——巧合的是，当时也正在发生一场全球大流行病，即 1918 年流感，5000 万人死亡。就在那时，从 1918 年起，右翼政客和报纸开始推动这个谎言，一种持续的、愤怒的报道鼓点，称实际上他们本可以赢得战争，如果犹太人和社会民主党人以及左派没有通过强迫德国投降而在背后捅刀子的话。
Even the creators of the stab in the back myth knew that they were lying-- the likes of Luddendorff, who later supported the Nazis. They knew well that the war was lost, was a lost cause.
即使是“背后捅刀传说”的创造者也知道他们在撒谎——比如鲁登道夫，他后来支持了纳粹。他们很清楚战争输了，是一场注定失败的斗争。
So after this myth begins, one of the things that you write is that there was no national consensus on the reality on what had happened to them. And it became impossible for a democracy to continue.
所以在这个神话开始后，你写道，关于他们身上发生了什么，现实中没有全国性的共识。民主国家变得无法继续下去。
Yes. That was quite true. And the disturbing effect of the stab in the back myth was that it did not grow weaker, but stronger over the years. You might have expected that eventually, people will see the truth. They will acknowledge the facts. They will believe what journalists and observers and historians tell them. But the contrary is true.
是的。那很正确。而“背后捅刀传说”令人不安的效果是，它并没有随时间推移而减弱，反而变得更强了。你可能预料到最终人们会看到真相。他们会承认事实。他们会相信记者、观察员和历史学家告诉他们的话。但事实恰恰相反。
That's actually one of the big things that I took from an op-ed that Jochen wrote about all this back in November, in The New York Times, that a lie like this might not die off on its own. It very well might stick around and grow in power.
这实际上是约亨在 11 月在《纽约时报》上撰写的关于这一切的评论文章中我所汲取的重大结论之一，即像这样的谎言可能不会自行消亡。它很有可能会留下来并不断壮大。
Throughout the 1920s, the idea that certain Germans were to blame for this defeat, for this big loss, was very seductive and very attractive. And I would go so far to say that if it hadn't been for the stab in the back myth, the Nazis could have never been as successful as they were.
在整个 20 年代，特定的德国人应该为这场失败、这场重大损失负责的想法非常有诱惑力，非常有吸引力。我甚至会说，如果不是因为“背后捅刀传说”，纳粹绝不可能像后来那样成功。
It was a central premise in Hitler's speeches and ideology. Now, to be clear, Jochen Bittner is deeply aware of the differences between America today and Germany in the 1920s. He is not saying that we should expect the rise of a new Adolf Hitler or something like that. But he is saying that what 1920s Germany shows us is how effective and popular an alternate reality can be in a country that's deeply polarized.
这是希特勒演讲和意识形态的一个核心前提。现在，明确一点，约亨·比特纳深刻地意识到今天的美国与 1920 年代的德国之间的差异。他并不是说我们应该期待一个新的阿道夫·希特勒的崛起之类的。但他是在说，1920 年代的德国向我们展示了在一个深度两极分化的国家里，一种另类现实是多么有效且受欢迎。
The other point along these lines that really has stayed with me and feels relevant to today in America is that back in the '20s, people who believed this myth saw their opponents as traitors, as people who had betrayed Germany in this basic fundamental way, which then justified anything that was done against them.
沿着这些思路，另一个真正留在我心头并让人觉得与今天的美国相关的一点是，早在 20 年代的德国，相信这个神话的人将他们的对手视为叛徒，视为以这种基本方式背叛了德国的人，这随后证明了对他们所做的一切都是合理的。
So the actual accusation was that all the people responsible for the so-called stab in the back were criminals, Novemberfabrican-- November criminals, who signed the armistice in November 1918. So the idea was that they were the ones who obstructed the legitimate course of history.
所以当时的实际指控是，所有对所谓“背后捅刀”负责的人都是罪犯，“十一月罪人”，是他们在 1918 年 11 月签署了停战协定。所以那个想法是，他们是阻碍历史进程的人。
Well, when you say that, it makes me think about the protesters at the Capitol who feel like the election's been stolen. Like, of course, extreme measures are called for. An election has been stolen from them.
嗯，当你这么说的时候，这让我想到了国会大厦的抗议者，他们觉得选举被窃取了。就像，当然，需要采取极端措施。选举从他们手中被窃取了。
But this is an interesting mindset, isn't it? I mean, we know it from people who are so convinced of the righteousness of their cause that they believe that even violence is legitimate to achieve their games. It's more or less a terrorist mindset or an extremist mindset, of course. They feel that they are the actual defenders of the true America. I mean, I read that Republicans who actually spoke out against Trump and against the stop the steal campaign, they now have to fear for their lives.
但这是一种有趣的思维方式，不是吗？我的意思是，我们从那些对自己的事业正当性深信不疑的人那里了解这一点，他们认为甚至是暴力也是实现目标的合法手段。这更多地是一种恐怖分子的心态或极端主义的心态，当然。他们觉得他们是真正美国的实际捍卫者。我的意思是，我读到那些实际上公开发声反对特朗普和反对“停止窃取”运动的共和党人，现在必须为自己的生命担忧。
I saw that too, the death threats against Republicans who voted to accept the election results. And back in the '20s in Germany, there was violence, starting with the German politician who negotiated their terms of surrender in World War I. He was murdered, a man named Mattias Erzberger. One of his assassins from a first failed assassination attempt went on trial and told the judge they did it because Erzberger stabbed the country in the back. When the judge asked him where he got this idea, he said, the newspapers.
我也看到了，针对投票接受选举结果的共和党人的死亡威胁。而在 20 年代的德国，也发生了暴力事件，从谈判第一次世界大战投降条件的德国政客开始。他被谋杀了，一个叫马蒂亚斯·埃尔茨贝格尔的人。他的一个第一次失败暗杀行动的刺客在受审时告诉法官，他们那样做是因为埃尔茨贝格尔在背后捅了国家一刀。当法官问他从哪里得到这个想法时，他说，报纸上。
So yeah, President Biden's in office, signing executive orders and talking about unity and trying to turn the page. But a lie this big? You didn't lose a war. You didn't lose an election. It can stick around and fester and grow. It can lead to people losing faith in the entire system of government. In fact, Germany stopped being a democracy by the '30s. And it can lead to violence.
所以是的，拜登总统上任了，签署行政命令，谈论团结，试图翻过这一页。但这么大的一个谎言呢？你没有输掉一场战争。你没有输掉一场选举。它可能会留下来，化脓并壮大。它可能导致人们对整个政府体系失去信心。事实上，德国在 30 年代就不再是一个民主国家了。它可能导致暴力。
Act Four, Quarantweening. So today's program is about losses that are unaccounted for. And one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, has been thinking about the lives of kids during this pandemic here, how to account for what they've lost. One kid in particular.
第四幕，“隔离期少年”。所以今天的节目是关于未被考虑到的损失。我们的制作人之一，查纳·乔菲-沃尔特，一直在思考疫情期间这里孩子们的生活，如何解释他们所失去的。特别是其中的一个孩子。
I saw him on Zoom last May. I'd gotten an email asking me to show up for some online rallies, and he was at one of them. The rallies were for youth programs in New York City, programs that were being considered for budget cuts. My kid's after school program was one of them.
去年 5 月我在 Zoom 上看到了他。我收到了一封邮件，请求我参加一些在线集会，他就在其中一个集会上。这些集会是为纽约市的青年项目举行的，这些项目正面临预算削减的考虑。我孩子参加的课后项目就是其中之一。
Hey, everybody. Welcome to the Fund Youth NYC Virtual Rally, man. How's everybody doing over here?
嘿，大家好。欢迎参加“资助纽约青年”虚拟集会，伙计们。大家在这里怎么样？
What's going on, y'all?
发生什么事了，各位？
Hey, throw the X up.
嘿，比个 X。
Doing well, doing well.
很好，很好。
It's so strange going back to this video now and seeing how psyched everyone is to be on Zoom together. There's families and staff from programs across the city. And people are practically giddy to see the people we used to see in the world in here.
现在回看这段视频，看到每个人在 Zoom 上相聚是多么兴奋，这真是太奇怪了。有来自全市各地的项目家庭和工作人员。大家对于看到我们曾经在现实世界中看到的人出现在屏幕里简直是欣喜若狂。
Let's do a selfie really quickly! If folks can just look at me, I'm going to take a picture. And then, we're going to post it on our social media. So are you ready?
快来拍张自拍！如果大家能看着我，我要拍张照。然后，我们会把它发布在我们的社交媒体上。那么你们准备好了吗？
I'd forgotten this time. Back then, last May, we still believed we could get our lives back. People in this rally say, well, obviously, we're going to need somewhere to send our kids. We can't just close all the places children go every day. A single dad says, innocently, parents need to keep their jobs. There's a program director. His budget is about to be cut. And he's saying, but I mean, we can't lay off hundreds of people in the middle of a pandemic. Come on.
我忘记了那个时刻。那时，去年 5 月，我们仍然相信我们可以找回我们的生活。参加这次集会的人说，嗯，很显然，我们将需要一个地方安置我们的孩子。我们不能只是关闭孩子们每天去的所有地方。一位单身父亲天真地说，父母需要保住他们的工作。有一位项目主任。他的预算正要被削减。他说，但我的意思是，我们不能在疫情期间裁掉数百人。拜托。
This is a lot of what the meeting was-- people talking about why their programs shouldn't be cut, especially parents and kids. The kid who has stuck with me many months later is a little boy who spoke. He's sitting up straight and stiff in a blue-collared shirt, clearly nervous.
会议大部分内容就是这样——人们谈论为什么他们的项目不应该被削减，尤其是父母和孩子。在许多个月后仍留在我脑海里的那个孩子，是一个发言的小男孩。他坐得笔直，穿着一件蓝色领子的衬衫，明显很紧张。
All right. Hi, everyone. My name is Joel Santana. And I just want to say that--
好的。嘿，大家好。我叫乔尔·桑塔纳。我只是想说——
At first, he caught my eye because he seemed so little. Most kids speaking were teenagers. He looked like he could be nine or 10. But when he spoke, it was clear he's older, in middle school. He talks like a kid who wants to sound like an adult and is eager for his vocabulary to catch up.
起初，他引起了我的注意，因为他看起来太小了。大多数发言的孩子都是青少年。他看起来像 9 岁或 10 岁。但当他说话时，很清楚他更大一些，在读初中。他说话像个想听起来像个成年人，并渴望自己的词汇量能跟上的孩子。
Throughout my time there, I got to know people and do engaging activities with them. And now, I can call them my friends.
在我那里的整个过程中，我结识了朋友，并和他们一起进行了引人入胜的活动。现在，我可以称他们为我的朋友了。
He's looking increasingly nervous-- maybe trying not to cry? I can't tell.
他看起来越来越紧张——也许在努力不哭？我看不出来。
Beacon Program really helps people in a community that don't really have anywhere to go after school. It really helps with the community. And sorry, one second.
“灯塔”项目确实帮助了社区里那些放学后无处可去的人。它真的帮助了社区。抱歉，等一下。
He turns off his camera. And we all just wait, looking at his black square. Is he coming back? 20 seconds pass.
他关掉了他的摄像头。我们都只是等待，看着他的黑色方块。他还会回来吗？20 秒过去了。
We love you, Joel.
我们爱你，乔尔。
Joel, it's Ozzy here. You got this, Joel.
乔尔，我是奥兹。你可以的，乔尔。
We love you.
我们爱你。
You got this.
你可以的。
He turns his camera back on and finishes.
他重新打开了摄像头并完成了发言。
I just wanted to say that-- I just want to emphasize that it would be such a loss to have some sort of cut that would sort of prohibit our-- like, our growth in the community. And it's so detrimental that youth like me have growth. Again, it would be such a loss to many kids.
我只是想说——我只是想强调，进行任何禁止我们——就像，阻碍我们在社区中成长的削减，将是一个巨大的损失。像我这样的青年有成长是非常重要的。再说一次，这对许多孩子来说将是一个巨大的损失。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thinking about what's been lost in this past year, I've wondered about Joel. How scared he seemed of losing his after school program. How scared he seemed in that moment. I wondered what was going on with him and if his program got cut and what that 20-second silence was about. Last week, I called him up, introduced myself, and asked him.
想到过去一年失去的东西，我一直在想乔尔。他看起来多么害怕失去他的课后项目。他在那一刻看起来多么害怕。我想知道他身上发生了什么，他的项目是否被削减了，那 20 秒的沉默是怎么回事。上周，我打电话给他，自我介绍并问了他。
So what was happening when you turned your camera off?
那么当你关掉摄像头时发生了什么？
I probably just, like, breathing in and out. Yeah, deep breath out. Because it's definitely a hard topic to talk about, and this was something that was definitely a big chunk of my life. And then, it was just taken away.
我可能只是，就像，在进行呼吸练习。是的，深呼吸。因为这绝对是一个难以谈论的话题，而且这是我生活中非常重要的一部分。然后，它就这样被带走了。
Joel told me he wrote out what he planned to say at the rally in advance. He practiced his comments, practiced them in different rooms in his apartment, considered if he should print them. No, he should hold them in his hand. No, he should put them to the side. Joel thought, somehow, if he said the right words in the exact right way, the program would come back.
乔尔告诉我，他事先写下了他计划在集会上说的话。他练习了他的评论，在公寓的不同房间里练习，考虑是否应该打印出来。不，他应该把它拿在手里。不，他应该把它放在一边。乔尔心想，不知何故，如果他用正确的方式说出了正确的话，项目就会回来。
It just felt so important that I made my point clear. I just think that doing this would basically ensure that I still have that part of my life.
我把观点表达清楚感觉非常重要。我只是认为这样做基本上会确保我依然拥有生活的那一部分。
Joel wanted that-- was so committed to saving his after school program because there was a big thing that happened to him there, something that was really big to him and is also really small. His mom, Saritza Lopez-Rodriguez, says you have to understand who Joel was before middle school.
乔尔之所以如此致力于拯救他的课后项目，是因为那里发生了一件对他来说的大事，一件对他来说真的很重要，同时也真的很小的事。他的母亲，萨里扎·洛佩兹-罗德里格斯说，你必须了解乔尔在读初中之前是谁。
There's a reason Joel speaks like an adult. He grew up around adults. It was always him and his mom. When he was little, Saritza used to take him to night school if she couldn't find childcare. When she went to law school, they lived in the dorms together. So Joel spent a lot of time around adults.
乔尔说起话来像个成年人是有原因的。他是在成年人身边长大的。总是他和他的母亲。他小时候，如果找不到人照顾，萨里扎会带他去上夜校。当她去上法学院时，他们住在一起。所以乔尔花了很多时间在成年人身边。
But with kids, he just could not connect. His mom tried sports programs. Joel was not a sports guy. She got him together with her friends' kids. He'd hang on her leg. She thought, maybe we need to move. They're Latino. Saritza thought maybe somewhere more diverse. Maybe he just needs to feel more included. So right before middle school, they moved to Queens.
但和孩子们，他就是无法建立联系。他妈妈尝试过体育项目。乔尔不是运动型。她让他和她朋友的孩子们在一起。他会粘着她的腿。她想，也许我们需要搬家。他们是拉美裔。萨里扎想也许去一个更多元化的地方。也许他只是需要感到更被包容。所以就在读初中之前，他们搬到了皇后区。
I tried to find a park with the most kids, right? And I was like, he's going to have to play with somebody here and socialize here. Because there were kids playing tag, and I kept on telling him. I was like, "Joel, just start running, right? Run, and they'll include you. They'll ask you if you want to play, right?" And he's like, "No." And you have a bunch of kids just playing tag, you know? We would stay out-- be there, like, two hours and nothing. He made this statement, and I was just like, OK. He goes, "Mom, you don't understand the social aspect of being a kid." And I was like, "OK?"
我试着找一个孩子最多的公园，对吧？我说，他必须在这里和别人玩，在这里社交。因为那里有孩子在玩抓人游戏，我一直告诉他。我说：“乔尔，就开始跑，对吧？跑，他们就会让你加入。他们会问你想不想玩，对吧？”他说：“不。”你有一群孩子在玩抓人游戏，你知道吗？我们会待在那儿——待在那儿，像两个小时，什么都没发生。他说了一句，我就像，好吧。他说：“妈妈，你不了解身为孩子的社交方面。”我就像：“好吧？”
He said those words?
他说了那句话？
Yes, he literally said those words. And I was just looking at him. I'm like, ahh.
是的，他字面意义上说了那句话。我只是看着他。我就像，啊。
Then, Joel started middle school. Saritza signed him up for the after school program, and that's when something big happened for Joel. He made a friend-- two, actually, in after school-- James and Richard. And then, walking home from after school one day, Joel met a kid named Daniel, who has become his best friend. Joel told me that could easily have never happened, the two of them crossing paths at the exact same time.
然后，乔尔开始读初中。萨里扎给他报名了课后项目，就在那时，乔尔身上发生了大事。他交了一个朋友——实际上在课后项目交了两个，詹姆斯和理查德。然后，有一天放学回家的路上，乔尔遇到了一个叫丹尼尔的孩子，他成了他最好的朋友。乔尔告诉我，那本可以轻易不会发生，他们两个在完全相同的时间跨过道路。
And if he would have went into his apartment in a millisecond, they probably would have not had a chance to actually meet and have a friendship.
如果他早一毫秒走进他的公寓，他们可能就没有机会真正见面并建立友谊了。
He says if Daniel went in just a millisecond sooner, they wouldn't have had a chance to meet and have a friendship.
他说如果丹尼尔早一毫秒走进去，他们就不会有机会见面并建立友谊了。
And what would that have meant for you?
那对你来说意味着什么？
Honestly, I don't know. Daniel really-- he definitely gave me a sense of having a best friend. And I just think that I haven't had that before, where a friend would come over to my house and just play video games and hang out.
老实说，我不知道。丹尼尔真的——他确实给了我一种拥有最好朋友的感觉。我只是觉得我以前没有过那种体验，朋友会到我家来一起玩电子游戏和消磨时光。
Joel said, I'm an only child. This was huge for him. And after that, he threw himself into the world in a way he had never done before. At lunchtime, he had a table of friends to sit with. He signed up for photography in after school. He ran for president of the after school student council, and he won.
乔尔说，我是独生子。这对他来说太重要了。在那之后，他以前所未有的方式投入到世界中。午餐时间，他有一桌朋友可以坐在一起。他报了课后摄影班。他竞选了课后学生会主席，而且赢了。
He saw a counselor one day, playing with devil sticks, sort of like juggling. And Joel begged his mom to get him some. Saritza told me he was obsessive about mastering it. It was the first time she'd seen him have a hobby. Joel was suddenly enthusiastically responding to the people and opportunities and chance encounters around him. He was mastering the social aspect of being a kid.
有一天，他看到一位辅导员在玩魔力棒，有点像杂耍。乔尔恳求他妈妈给他买一些。萨里扎告诉我，他痴迷于掌握它。这是她第一次看到他有业余爱好。乔尔突然热情地回应着周围的人、机会和偶然的相遇。他正在掌握身为孩子的社交方面。
And then, in the middle of seventh grade, with the pandemic, after school shut down. It went before regular school closed. And those first few weeks were jarring, getting home early, letting himself into the house.
然后，在七年级年中，随着疫情爆发，课后项目关闭了。它在正常学校关闭之前就停了。那最初的几周真是令人不安，早早回家，自己开门进屋。
And it didn't feel right. It didn't feel normal.
感觉不对劲。感觉不正常。
What did you do with your time?
你把时间花在什么上了？
I don't know. I ate a snack. It just felt blank. I just found myself either just lying down on my bed and just bored. It's just been an overwhelming sense of just boredom all the time.
我不知道。我吃了点零食。感觉就是一片空白。我发现自己要么就是躺在床上，感到无聊。一直有一种挥之不去的极度无聊感。
That has not gone away. Joel's mom told me sometimes she still finds him lying on the bed. No phone or book, just staring at the ceiling. Right when his world should have been getting bigger, it's gotten so much smaller. He goes from his bedroom to the living room to the kitchen. He talks to his mom. I asked if he sees friends in online school. Joel said, yeah, but it's not the same. I asked if he calls his best friend, Daniel. He says, yeah.
这种感觉并没有消失。乔尔的妈妈告诉我，有时她还会发现他躺在床上。没带手机或书，只是盯着天花板。就在他世界本该变得更大的时候，它却变得如此之小。他从卧室走到客厅再走到厨房。他和妈妈说话。我问他是否在网课中见到朋友。乔尔说，有，但不一样。我问他是否给最好的朋友丹尼尔打电话。他说，有。
Again, it's not the same.
同样，那不一样。
Yeah. I was just thinking, listening to you, I know there's a lot of concern about learning loss, like kids missing out on the things that you would normally learn in middle school, like developing your writing skills and learning algebra and geometry. Do you think there are things that are not accounted for on that list?
是的。我刚才在想，听你说话，我知道人们很关心学习损失，比如孩子们错过了他们在初中通常会学到的东西，比如发展你的写作技巧和学习代数几何。你认为清单上是否还有未被考虑到的事情？
Some of my friends-- honestly, I have lost connection with a lot of my friends because of this. And I really wish it would be different. But I think the most that's not accounted for is the social aspect that you're supposed to have. That is one of the biggest losses.
我的一些朋友——老实说，因为这个，我和许多朋友失去了联系。我真的希望会有所不同。但我认为最未被考虑到的是你本应该拥有的社交方面。那是最大的损失之一。
The social aspect.
社交方面。
Yeah.
是的。
And you had just gotten that.
而且你刚刚才拥有那个。
Yeah.
是的。
There are the losses we know have been suffered by children this past year. Kids have lost family members. They've lost learning, stability, sometimes access to food. There are the losses we know, but what does it mean to lose your 13th year in the world? What would have happened for Joel?
过去一年孩子们所遭受的损失是众所周知的。孩子们失去了家庭成员。他们失去了学习、稳定，有时失去了获取食物的机会。有我们知道的损失，但失去你在这个世界上的第 13 年意味着什么？乔尔本会发生什么？
In just one year, he made a friend. He learned how to make his way through a middle school cafeteria, how to look around and say, no, not that table. Not there. Yes, here. This is the place for me. He found his first hobby. He learned he could ask his peers to vote for him and his ideas, and they would. What else might have happened? No one ever says you're only 39 once. But you really are only 13 once.
仅仅一年，他交了一个朋友。他学会了如何在初中食堂里穿梭，如何环顾四周说：不，不是那一桌。不在那里。是的，在这里。这是属于我的地方。他找到了他的第一个爱好。他了解到他可以请求同龄人为他投票，支持他的想法，而他们会支持。还可能发生什么？从没人说过你只有 39 岁一次。但你确实只有 13 岁一次。
Joel finished seventh grade at home. He'll probably finish eighth grade at home, too. And the next time he steps foot in a school building, it'll be to start high school. He's never going back to middle school. That's gone. Whoever he might have become, that's gone, too.
乔尔在家完成了七年级。他可能也会在家完成八年级。而他下次踏入学校大楼时，将是开始上高中。他再也不会回到初中了。那已经过去了。无论他可能成为什么样的人，那也已经过去了。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our show. If you have not heard her podcast, Nice White Parents, that she made with the Serial team, it's available wherever you get your podcasts.
查纳·乔菲-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人之一。如果你还没听过她和 Serial 团队制作的播客《Nice White Parents》，它在你获取播客的地方都可以听到。
[MUSIC - "EN CASITA" BY BAD BUNNY"]
[音乐 - Bad Bunny 的《En Casita》]
Our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman. The people who put our show together today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Grave, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Lina Misitizis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ari Saperstein, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sara Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们今天的节目由纳迪亚·雷曼制作。今天整理我们节目的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔纳·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、达米安·格雷夫、查纳·乔菲-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、米基·米克、莉娜·米西蒂齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、阿里·萨珀斯坦、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Paul Hamilos, Rachel Lissy, Luis Fuentes, Lauren Yee, Harrison Nesbit, Felix, and Igor Bobic. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's lists of favorite shows, videos we've made over the years, links to our television program, and tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天特别感谢保罗·哈米洛斯、瑞秋·利西、路易斯·富恩特斯、劳伦·伊、哈里森·内斯比特、费利克斯和伊戈尔·博比奇。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。你可以完全免费收听我们超过 700 集的节目档案。此外，网站上还有最受欢迎的节目列表、我们多年来制作的视频、我们电视节目的链接以及海量其他内容。再说一遍，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构 PRX 提供给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he's redoing the drywall in his house. He's got all the supplies-- trowel, sandpaper, ladder. It took him a long time. He was covered in white dust, or as he puts it--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他正在重做家里的干墙。他有所有的补给品——泥刀、砂纸、梯子。这花了他很长时间。他浑身覆盖着白色的灰尘，或者正如他所说的——
By the end of the day, like, totally plastered.
一天结束时，就像，醉得一塌糊涂。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "EN CASITA" BY BAD BUNNY"]
[音乐 - Bad Bunny 的《En Casita》]